this is 13 pages Salaam alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh yeah pies I
been so Judas dejan ver SI può favo
participant program the dish 00 sec us a
babushka moot obrigado Brazil who stays
at Ella cha cha hello everyone please
join us in a Dean show and pretty sure
you guys are gonna find a good segment
tonight thank you this is 1330 this is
the things the teacher this is the thing
is the theme jus this is the things
this is the view peace be unto you
salaam alaikum alaikum Salaam on fire
after to the Boehner to the bank to the
bone was that me now for the people that
don't understand Portuguese Brazilian so
that means what's up how's it going how
are you now I mean you just hit home man
because I've been so excited you know I
come from a background that I've been
trained in Brazilian jiu-jitsu okay the
the people my teacher is they originate
from Brazil right and some of the I mean
some of them are the nicest friendliest
people you know and they're really
welcoming and warm and you know I used
to travel there to Train Brazilian
jiu-jitsu and I always wanted to and I
have shared you know with many of them
the purpose of life and trying to you
know talk to them about this but it's
different when they hear someone who's
from the culture from the background and
your Brazilian and in a predominantly
Catholic environment now how did you how
did you end up becoming a Muslim one who
submitted to the will of god that's what
a Muslim is in your Brazilian houses
were exactly you know sometimes I think
you know every time we talk about Brazil
the first thing that comes out of
people's mouths is carnival the beach is
the surfing and I'm not going to say the
other items that tends to be the
stereotypical you know but you know like
you said you know it's a predominantly
Catholic culture and it mostly like I
said when we say Catholic doesn't mean
that the people necessarily follow those
those beliefs it's more of a cultural
thing and for me growing up I kind of
grew up in the the cultural side of the
Catholic faith just you know Christmas
New Year's and but when it came in
February carnival you partied up and you
did everything that you really weren't
supposed to do right and then you get
back again and you repent and you do all
the stuff again but for me I think the
pivotal point in my life was when I
immigrated to the u.s. in 1990 you know
I think and I actually came by myself I
remember I was nine years old and the
stewardess talking to me in English I
could understand a word they were saying
but for me it was this melting pot this
cultural shock of just coming to the US
and meeting people of
four nations and different songs in
different colors and different
backgrounds and that was really an
eye-opener for me and while I was in
Brazil like I said I grew up in a place
called huge shiny new Rio de Janeiro
Brazil that's where you were born you go
rio de janeiro here do shiny oh yeah
that's why people you say it low with
how do you say properly huge shiny
appeal because the art would h exactly
here and then usually people from real
we call him KD vodka so if you're from
reeled I think the Brazilian audience
they probably know what I'm talking
about considered a Carioca because
that's kind of like the nickname you
know like see from New York or New
Yorker so we say I'm a Carioca I'm from
Rio exactly now you also trained
Brazilian Jujitsu you know the Gracie's
who are the developers of this art that
came over to the United States and had
the ultimate they the ones that
developed an ultimate fighting
championship and they prove without a
shadow of a doubt that it is the most
effective martial art in the world
that's how they became known you know
about you obviously know about the
Gracie's yeah absolutely no you know
growing up in Brazil you know we always
heard about the the family gracie the
family Gracie and and I did capoeira I
think most people probably know cup
withers and other traditional martial
arts that was actually started by the
African slaves first disguised as kind
of like a dance and ritual but really it
was more of a training technique to
protect themselves from the plantation
owners but growing up in Brazil you know
and the beach and that environment you
know I think there's a lot of machismo
rice so I did have a lot of friends who
were digits of fighters but really for
me my family wanted me to do more of the
traditional Taekwondo and capoeira but
when I came to the US I really got into
grappling I wrestled a part of my middle
school year and when I joined the Marine
Corps the Marine Corps has its own
martial arts program MCMAP so it's a lot
of grappling and actually talking about
the gracie they introduced a lot of the
grappling from the Gracie family so you
know Hickson gracie I've seen him a
couple of times i met him in Dixon yeah
for audience that doesn't know who Hicks
and Gracie is you know they know switch
[ __ ] they think that's a real strong
guy yeah I know Muhammad Ali but Hicks
and Gracie you know in his time or even
till the day's an undefeated martial
artist hilarious people don't know that
it was like four hundred and old
exactly yeah and I think it kind of goes
into and I know probably the viewers you
know they don't know about the stir
about ho khana right who was a companion
of the prophet peace be upon him in this
particular companion he was somebody who
I guess at that time would say he was
kind of like to hixson grey see if we
can try to compare right there so he was
somebody at the time in Arabia that
nobody can beat him down no one can take
him down and here comes you know this
undefeated ultimate wrestler grappler
going to the beloved Prophet peace be
upon him and challenging him now only
wants the only twice but the third time
and then finally the third time he says
a shadow and I like and Allah said o
muhammad rasool allah meaning i be
witnessed and testified that is only one
God and that the Prophet Muhammad is a
final messenger so i think when i became
a muslim and I and I and I came across
that prophetic saying you really kind of
just opened my eyes in my bollocks it's
an incredible story just to see that
this man was able to say no what I was
knocked down and this is the prophet of
Allah but yeah I always think about
Hickson grace and i always think about
the story of Luke anna and i just psa'd
say it's something that i can equate you
know between the two of them i know a
lot of the Brazilians they can relate if
they look into Islam their submission to
the will of God they see that it's
something rational is logical you know
many of them have good etiquettes good
manners you know good character just you
know nice people in general so is there
what kind of Muslim outreach is there is
there I know when I was there I found a
smaller mush it was like one percent
Muslims there and how can we like you
know do more to help deliver the message
of the purpose of life you know to the
people in that neck and that part of the
world yeah Brazil is a very big country
and it's actually part of the acronym
brick which a British economist actually
came up with that terminology so Brazil
Russia India and China so it's a it's a
country that's developing very fast and
I don't know I don't know if the
there's no you know but actually in 2014
the world cup is going to be in Brazil
and in 2016 the Olympics so there's a
lot of Muslims Brazilian Muslims like
myself there are a lot of pursuing that
are accepting Islam especially in the
city of San Paulo because there's a big
Lebanese community in Brazil and through
those immigrants who came obviously they
bought in Islam but you do have a lot of
people except in Islam and Rio the
problem is you have a beach culture
beach environment and and it kind of
tends to be more of a challenge you know
how do you go ahead and present this
beautiful way of life but Brazilians are
very down-to-earth they love you people
they're very friendly and I'm pretty
sure you know that already yeah and I
think as part of my culture that's what
it is you know we say where our meetings
we're friends and they're very
hospitable people as well and I think
this is part of the nature of the people
there maybe has something to do to
tropical climate but when I went there a
couple of times you know to visit my
family to go to business you know the
first thing and when they see they see
the beard you know they see the the Hat
the Kofi and they think all wisata be no
you're Arab and you know but they see it
in a friendly way and then usually know
there's a lot of stereotypes which are
going to call prickliness a truce so
usually have to break away those
stereotypes and once you break away
those stereotypes are like well I didn't
even know that I don't know that I don't
know that muslims believe in Jesus that
know there's a chapter in the Quran
called you no soda to medium the chapter
of Mary we didn't know that Abraham
Moses these are all prophetic you know
profits that got sent in humanity so
once you start explaining to them these
things it's really an eye opening
because unfortunately the media they're
just like anywhere you know they give a
lot of false claims about Islam so I
think once you start addressing the real
issues that the people say I want more I
want more Killam Isaac atomized so and
then that's when you really you know
begin the work of Dawa propagating in
Psalm the creator of the heavens in the
earth the One God the same guy that
Jesus worship Abraham Moses the Creator
who created creation you know through
his last a final messenger we know that
is it saying that if you're not thankful
to the people you not think for the god
so I know myself I'm very thankful to
this family the Gracie family that I got
to benefit and learn this art that I'm
getting to pass on to others teaching
people how to defend themselves in
certain situations you know training
healthy lifestyle they even caught a
Gracie diet wonderful people and I you
know to give back you know I can give
them let's say money or you know give
them a house a car you know these
material things that you know they'll
perish you know at the end but I feel
the greatest gift that we can give is to
share this message of peace purpose
Islam if we can share it with them so
hopefully some of them you know are
tuning in I'm good friends with a lot of
them and come to the law thinks is to
the crater that I got a Brazilian Muslim
on the show so let's dwell into this
before we go to break you know a beach
volleyball and not the beach drinking
and all these at parties and all that
stuff but you know most people is not
satisfying to the soul you know what I
mean just chasing your lusts and desires
you were living that like carnival and
you know just a freestyle lifestyle you
know why is it important to think to
ponder about purpose of life why have I
been created I'm going to die soon where
am I going when I die you thought about
these questions you believe all the time
and the time that I grew up in Brazil in
Rio there was a lot of violence and I
know you've been to Rio and the thing
but real is that you know you have the
riches of places in poverty is right in
your face Eddie you know you have the
favelas the slums and growing up in this
economical injustice you know you saw a
lot of hostility so growing up I
remember times in Brazil I didn't have
the group you know the pretty yellow bus
i had a walk to school you know actually
close to two miles up a hill and there
was a time this season where you know
just like maybe you're driving down the
road and you see a dead squirrel but
there are times that you know as a young
man is a young boy I saw a lot of dead
people in the shoot because the violence
was so so strong and I think seeing that
as a young child seeing that wow you
know this this physical state it's gonna
it's going to die one day I'm not gonna
be here so at a very young age you know
beans you know seemed death like that
right in front of your face I've always
asked you know you know what's the
purpose of life why am I here and and I
think that's something that from a very
beginning God was already calling me was
already you know calling me to the
straight path to this way of life and
and it's something that a lot of
Brazilians you know at that time even
now there's still a lot of violence but
as things are changing you know as
anywhere it's becoming materialistic but
you still have people
or humble who are down on earth and they
know that all this material having fun
Cannavale and join although the beach
life you know I think after a point you
kind of said I did everything that was
the situation with me you know i did
everything at a young age i experienced
everything and after that you say what
else and i think once you hit that point
you know that's when there's a void and
you start saying wow you know what else
I have done everything what else do I do
and then for me it was you know a new
life experience and like I said I'm a
very young age you know sing death and
going through I knew that experience I
think is something that kind of woke me
up and choked me up and say you know I
need to find what's the purpose of life
I need to go ahead and discover who is
the creator of the heavens and earth and
I begin that journey I begin that
journey and all praise be to god I'm
here and I'm grateful to be a Muslim and
and most importantly being grateful to
be in a country where we have freedom of
religion and even though I never had the
privilege prior to Islam to know what
Muslim you know I read about Malcolm X
hydra-matic al-shabab's and just reading
his autobiography especially when he
went to Mecca and he said I sit next to
my brother with the blond hair and blue
eyes you know I always gives me the
goosebumps because it's just an amazing
story and every since i read that
autobiography i wanted more i wanted
more and then you know eventually i
think the main thing that caught my
attention was a PBS program was you know
getting Dawa from a public broadcasting
station I don't know if you ever heard
of the religion and ethics program in
PBS so I was actually watching a program
with my pole wolf was a Muslim convert
he did a lot of beautiful production
American yes American broadcast exactly
and this particular show it was a story
about two Americans who accepted Islam I
remember Sunday morning sitting there
and watching this program and being like
wow I wonder I want to follow that way
of life I want to experience that piece
that they're experiencing and I remember
the next day you know college guy in New
Jersey at that time and obviously all
tatted up and I remember I went to
school and that's when I actually made a
decision to go to the Muslim Student
Association at Montclair State
University and meet the Muslims we're
going to continue on with your story and
we're going to start giving some
evidence because
mom is not something that just overtakes
you you get full of something and you
have this mystical experience Islam is
calling you the craters calling you to
reflect and think and is based this
truth is based on proof on evidence is
that right that's right we're going to
dig some more Tom some Portuguese we
write back agua de mis amigas porfavor
spare moment shimka [ __ ] deals over
said I was on this show del all that
song fetch out everybody in deep down
they believe that there is a God yeah
and as much as they deny if God exists
and he does if God sends prophets and he
does if God reveals books and he does
should he not tell me how to live my
life doesn't that make sense they feel
more secure and safe now inside the
aridity of the slam than they ever felt
out in the streets
but the best way to bring true profound
happiness trooper found peace trooper
found tranquility is by following the
guidance that God has given see for
yourself what Islam has to say because
it really is the path to happiness and
truth in life it comes to you the truth
and the attribute of the one who created
you that he's won and alone running this
universe that he doesn't become bored he
doesn't die he doesn't eat and go to the
bathroom this is not God problem cares
yeah is this it doesn't make sense who
was Jesus worshipping this is recorded
in the Gospels despite all of the other
issues about the Gospels you put those
aside with the Saints mentioned there
with Jesus worship God one wit takes us
from hunger I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
allies by my side I am not afraid to
stay alone I am not afraid to stand
alone if allah SWA
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if allies by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone
someone's your fault on the Dean show
welcome back to the Dean show hey man
what's going on we starting again
without me man haha hamdullah listen now
okay party is getting played out you
know you've had all the money and you've
had all this Fame and many people
they're chasing these vain pursuits but
def comes into reality you know it's a
party stumper you just don't want to
talk about it but we're all going to die
and there's a purpose to life and the
one who organized life there is a
creator I mean most Brazilians don't
they believe that you know what this
whole universe and everything in it
didn't just happen by chance absolutely
absolutely I mean and that's something
that in my culture and the way I grew up
you know an open society and being
taught to respect people of different
backgrounds I mean you do overall you
Brazilians tend to be aware and keen
about the spirituality you know you know
they talk about spirit of the
spirituality of life and you know the
purpose of life and you know what is the
afterlife you know that's something that
you have a lot of Brazilians who
actually you know look into that subject
about their hereafter afterlife and
obviously we don't believe in
reincarnation but we do know that we
will be resurrected by our Creator and
we will face what they say in Portuguese
giada's excuses you know Judgment Day so
you do have a lot of Brazilians who
believe in that and obviously as Muslims
we know that our Creator Allah God that
we will be before our Creator on the day
of judgment so tell us now design
obviously indicates a designer and we're
intelligent human beings so we know that
there has to be someone who's
responsible everything that's the
Creator right so now what was it you
believed in a creator you partied your
life at one point you were partying
having a good time and now you're like
okay I got to figure out the purpose of
life def came into equation you're like
I'm going to die but it figured this out
before I die and then what was it about
this way of life Islam submission to the
will of God that captivated your
attention even more so the evidence is
to prove so the Brazilian whoever else
in the world I need some proof I don't
want to follow organized religion
organized by man
or men I want to I want to follow a way
of life that is from the crater not a
human being absolutely and you know what
these are all important questions and
even myself before becoming a Muslim
anyone who submits to the will of God
how do you say that in Portuguese
musulman and sumona Muslim and what how
do you translate king should be mad
shadows one who submits two god that's
it okay so I you know I had all those
concepts and i went from Episcopalian
boarding school in boca raton florida
and obviously not having to go to Chapel
three times a day and having gone to
like of religious type spoon
Episcopalian which is a sect of
christianity and being always learning
learning the scripture and trying to
understand the scripture you know
whatever variation whatever language I
always wanted to understand the
scripture and I think for me after I had
my medical discharge from the Marine
Corps and going through a difficult
experience during my training a
near-death experience I think that
really was an eye-opener in when I moved
back to New Jersey and I went to college
and studying anthropology I think that
was another way of learning different
cultures learning different languages
and one particular course we studied
what's called you know the cultures of
the Middle East and in that particular
course and I really learned a lot about
what is the Middle East and what are the
different cultures and obviously Islam
there's a lot of Muslims in the Middle
East and when I begin to search and
watching that program on PBS I think you
know to those people who say well I
don't want to follow organized religion
but I'll tell you something I never
planned I never wrote down in my agenda
that in 2004 november two thousand and
for a college student i was going to go
to the muslim student association that i
was going to go there and become a
Muslim because the way it happened as
you know Here I am philippa matchings
Felipe Martins you know a guy from huge
n go to Brazil Here I am and for me and
it happened as if I give Isabella God
like it was something that that was the
will of God and it's sometimes people
they want something tangible right you
want something that they can feel and
the feeling that I had is like going
there
and seen the Muslims and being welcomed
and I'll tell you Eddie I never knew
what the word Shahada was which for your
heroes I don't know if they know the
declaration of faith but everything that
I'm Muslim believed I already believed I
believed that the one got the creator of
the heavens and earth because I'll tell
you when my grandmother had the image of
Jesus peace be upon him as a blonde hair
blue-eyed fair-skinned not that there's
anything wrong with that you know you
sir just the pigmentation of your skin
but that was the image of what my
grandmother told me that's God and as a
young a young child imagined I see how
can God be a created thing and I
remember and I would ask that the priest
would just say we have to have faith you
know how do I have to go to you to seek
forgiveness and I seek the forgiveness
from the one who created you and I so as
a young child I think that's something
that's called the fit that it's an eight
and when I went to to the Muslim Student
Association i really had those beliefs
so for me it was a desire to go back to
something that hours i was already part
of and i remember one of the brothers
you know he said well you should take
your Shahada but I remember Eddie I said
you know what I went to shahad the way
the Shahada you know having minimum
fraternity I said okay where's the
ritual but it was an old bunkin in the
water or doing some crazy ritual it was
just sincerely declaring that I bear
witnessed and testified that there's
only one duty with your worship which we
say Allah Arabic and that the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him is the final
messenger and I believe that especially
after I read the book I believe we
covered it in one of your shows the 100
most influential people in history and I
read that as a student and I was amazed
by the character of Muhammad peace be
upon him and having been in the military
not only from the military aspect from a
statement a father and just seeing this
wonderful man and I think you know that
was another way that really caught my
attention reading about who is the
Prophet Muhammad and that really opened
up so much doors for me just to say I
want to emulate and follow in his
footsteps now what was at the end so you
took this step forward you found out
that Islam was true based on proof and
then you took the show how that you've
declared that there's nothing worthy of
worship except the creator of the
heavens and earth and Muhammad is the
last and final messenger your
relationship with Jesus did it get cut
off it didn't
get caught off if anything it became
more clear and evident because Jesus
himself never proclaimed nor did he ever
say because obviously nowadays no one
speaks Aramaic no one speaks to actual
language and obviously Bible comes from
the Greek word biblioth so just to make
a long story short you know after
studying extensively and I wanted to
become a pastor I wanted to actually go
into that route so I began to read a lot
of a very young age all the different
versions of the Bible but if anything he
made it more clear in crystalline
understanding that Jesus the Son of Mary
Alice into this earth for the people at
that time was a way for people to be
guided to the right way and that
particular time in place and that the
Prophet Muhammad is the final he's
called the Hutt Amanda being he's the
seal of the prophets if anything it made
it much more clear and I think it's you
can't just blind follow anything you
have to seek the truth and seek
knowledge and be objective and try to
understand because once you really are
sincere God will guide you to the right
way we're going to come back with more
to wrap it up here on the Dean show
don't go nowhere when outside everything
looks good you see the
hundred-thousand-dollar cars you see a
lot of diamonds you see a lot of females
and they think that this is you know
this is a life this is this is like no
paradise right here
with just my job to go into someone's
heart to change the heart your job is to
topi what the truth is in the alley over
there is while we're sitting here while
i'm sitting here constantly paying for
the disease the kill was free and if
we're going to worship something I
figured I might as well worship the
Creator instead of any of the creations
now in upon investigating the villages I
remember finding out the meaning of what
Islam is what Muslim is those who
surrender yourself to God is a Muslim
those who surrender submit to God God's
will that is it Islam was pure it was
just you just pray to God your Creator I
am not afraid to stand I am not afraid
to stand alone if allies by my side I am
Not Afraid
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand back here on the Dean
show with Philippe Philippe Philippe to
the bone to the bay mom you go all right
and we are reaching out to all of
humanity especially the people that
really dear to my heart the Brazilians
and we know about the Gracie family
hixson Gracie hoist Gracie I was just
with the Gracie who his father brought
the ultimate fighting championship here
henner Gracie and we tried a carlos
gracie jr. as my teacher marcio feitosa
so many people to mention henzo Gracie
you know henzo Gracie and so many of the
graces that I really you know love
dearly and we really want to share this
purpose of life with them so continue on
we're almost out of time so again
helping people such as themselves who
are successful and they have so much and
why do you feel it's important like you
did to stop and reflect that look I
should be thankful to God the Creator
who created me and you mentioned we
mentioned Jesus many people are
connected to Jesus but as am as a Muslim
that and cut your connection up there's
confusion over this man but aslam
cleared it up that Jesus was a mighty
messenger of god never did he ever say
he was God right he called people to
worship God absolutely and from there
you you figured out that this has to be
the truth so give us some other things
that you feel that they can relate to
from your experiences that will help
them along the way to at least you know
stop every flight and look into this
some more investigators form an
investigation look into the Quran the
rated verbatim word of God and do some
homework absolutely and kind of just
going back to you know at that at that
particular point in my life Eddie when
when I was searching for the truth I was
searching for what is the right way and
what's my purpose of life and I think
you know everybody you know at one point
or another we always ponder and you say
you know what you know
you think about a ticket the boarding
pass and you know that the boarding pass
there's a time of departure and I I say
that to my Brazilian among demons and
brethren my brothers and sisters in
humanity that you know what we have this
departure ticket and we have a departure
time and all of us will face that
particular particular time but we don't
know when so i think is we have to
prepare and in preparing that in this
wonderful way of life it's a way of life
that brings success not only in this
life but God willing and the hereafter
and it's a way of life that brings about
so many good things booij squeezes good
things things that will make you a
better person a better father brother
son a brother husband whatever it is if
you're a professor in jiu-jitsu it's
going to make you a better professional
version so if you're a competitor in
jiu-jitsu it's going to make your better
competitor in jiu-jitsu and i say that
because i find that now that i'm a
muslim and things are so much clearer
right I'm not chained I'm not enslaved
by what culture and what society wants
you to be because if you become enslaved
by what society one should it be you're
never going to fully evolved as a human
being and that's what I wanted to do I
don't want to be in shackled by what
society wanted me to be how I have to
love what kind of car I have to have how
much money God doesn't care if you have
one cent or a billion dollars in the
bank or if you drive a Ferrari or a
hoopty as we say in my neck of the woods
so it's more about who you are as a
person who you are as a human being
before we leave just in Portuguese break
down some of the the main crust of the
matter of Islam and we can go expound on
this for so long but we only have like I
give you like 30 a minute in Portuguese
and then just break it down summarized
in English go ahead tell me who's motor
brigade watch pacquiao show do Dean do
brother Eddie primeira coisa islam nete
a multiplicity of Islam Islam arrow kami
models na sang de todos profitez
profited on LeBron jewish village Mario
you Schmo perfeito Mahama que paso stage
hakuna d equal sectors OCC booze Esch
paswan tempeh tempeh Queenie cos LOM sak
concept SI vamos a massaging amano g2g
vue de he possessed ezza becoming
illumina a Soviet the multiple God now
what you say briefly just real quickly
just saying that Islam is a way of life
it's it's a way that brings about
success and it's the message that all
the profits from Adam Abraham know where
Jesus the Son of Mary in the last
prophet mohammed it's a way of life that
it brings about success and it's a way
of life that for sure it's going to make
you a better human being thank you very
much oh my god I'm ready the crater a
lot of reward you for being with thank
you so much and now was it another
episode of the Dean show when you die
and we will all die and there's only a
few things that follow us to the grave
I'm telling you right now this is the
truth this is the truth your family will
follow you and your wealth will follow
you and then your actions what you did
in this life but the only thing that's
going to carry on over with you to the
next knife are your actions your wealth
and your material goods stay behind and
the only thing that you can take with
your your action in the best action that
you can have in this life is to work to
please your Creator before you meet him
to worship the creator and not his
creation not to worship Jesus not to
worship Moses Muhammad but to worship
the God who created this whole universe
and everything in it the same God that
Jesus worship the same God that all of
mankind profess that created this
creation that's the one God so now is
the chance to reflect why have I been
created where am I going when I die and
now is the time to beseech to ask to ask
the creator for guidance before it's
done and then you got the hill fire in
front of you and paradise now you can
extend your head for paradise me to work
for it so work right now hard in this
life to be the best that you can be
following God's gaming plan not your
desires so we hope you got to benefit 1
866 to Islam and read this book the car
and pick it up read it you read
everything else we'll see you next time
peace be unto you
this is the biju this is the danger